supongamos ahora que tenemos un campo
vectorial ve como ya es costumbre
llamarlo y este en cualquier punto dado
es igual a menos menos menos ok vamos a
poner menos llegue como magnitud en la
dirección x ok
y ahora vamos a sumarle algo que dependa
sólo de x por ejemplo x en la dirección
del vector j suficiente ahora vamos a
comprobar todo esto y encontrar su
rotacional así que el rotacional debe el
rotacional debe es igual al operador nav
la cruz v
correcto
ahora lo que podemos ver es que a pesar
de que parece un campo vectorial en dos
dimensiones lo podemos pensar en uno de
tres verdad si queremos obtener el
producto cruz realmente tenemos que
pensar en de campos vectoriales de
dimensión tres así que esta dirección
pues claramente va a resultar
perpendicular al plano xy verdad bueno
si ya tiene suficiente intuición podemos
ver que podemos tomar un vector
resultante que depende de sólo dos
vectores en el plano así que cuando
realizamos el producto cruz tenemos que
hacerlo en tres dimensiones como hacemos
esto pues como ya sabemos ponemos
nuestros tres vectores canónicos y jk y
ahora ponemos la parcial respecto de x
parcial respecto de ye y parcial
respecto de z que son las componentes
del operador nabla y luego menos ponemos
x y al final un 0 verdad porque podemos
pensar a b
sumándole 0 en la última componente así
que esto será equivalente a veamos
multiplicamos y quitamos columna y
renglón y nos queda el determinante de
aquella sub matriz que es parcial
respecto de 70 menos la parcial de zeta
de x
muy bien y esto lo multiplicamos por
nuestro vector y ahora vamos a restar
porque acuérdense que para el
determinante ponemos más menos más y
ahora ponemos el menos correspondiente a
jota y tomamos la parcial respecto de x
de cero menos la parcial respecto de z
de menos de verdad ojo con los signos
esto es menos
muy bien y ahora esto multiplica al
vector j
finalmente sumamos lo que corresponde a
la componente k que es la parcial
respecto de x en x + perdón menos la
parcial respecto de y de menos aquí ya
no lo alcanzan a ver pero que quede
claro que son menos y todo eso
multiplica acá ahora vamos a simplificar
lo vamos a simplificar esto primero este
término pues es un cero porque es la
derivada parcial de cero derivada
parcial de zeta de x pues como x es
constante
simplemente se anula ahora la parcial
respecto de x de cero es cero y la
parcial respecto de zeta de menos pues
es cero porque ya es una constante para
lo que le toca a z verdad ahora lo único
que nos queda es esto último vamos a
tachar todo esto vamos a quitarlo
muy bien ahora desde el punto de vista
de x la rotación es una es bueno si
pensamos la rotación irá en la dirección
perpendicular tanto de x como en la de y
por eso es que solo nos queda un vector
en la dirección ortogonal al plano x de
verdad entonces pues por eso es
intuitivo pensar que se anula todo lo
que tenga que ver con jota si eso no te
confunden no te apures aquí ya lo
estamos calculando pero bueno de todas
formas vamos a simplificar esto así que
nos queda la parcial respecto de x de x
pues es uno verdad y ahora menos la
parcial respecto de y de menos
eso simplemente es un -1 por tanto esto
es igual a 2 y falta multiplicarlo por
el vector k que va en la dirección del
eje z verdad entonces el rotacional en
cualquier punto es constante eso es lo
importante y lo cual es bastante
consistente con la intuición ahora
traigamos este ejemplo esto es hay que
hacerlo un poquito más grande
pero bueno este es el campo vectorial
creo que es suficientemente claro verdad
porque este parece que es un giro si nos
apegamos especialmente en el centro es
muy claro que el centro giraría pero
esto puede ser no sé a lo mejor podría
girar algo más rápido afuera de lo que
gire en el centro entonces porque
obtuvimos dos como rotacional bueno el
rotacional es el mismo en todo el campo
vectorial y eso quiere decir que el
campo está haciendo que algo gire de la
misma forma sin importar dónde estés
veamos si esto tiene sentido bueno en el
centro definitivamente lo tiene verdad
pero si yo tuviera una varita aquí
afuera y empujará con la dirección del
campo vectorial pues bueno le empujaría
hacia abajo a la derecha en esta
dirección de tal forma que causara que
girará pero qué pasaría si tuviera la la
varita más alejada tú dirías bueno
encima te estoy empujando hacia arriba
ya la izquierda no y en la parte de
abajo a la izquierda
pues a lo mejor no giraría tanto pero la
diferencia en esas magnitudes de esos
dos se podría ver casi como que las
fuerzas que producen la torsión en
realidad es suficiente para que aún
tengan la misma rotación en sentido
contrario a las manecillas del reloj
verdad
por ello el rotacional es un número
positivo constante cuando cuando miras
el plano x y si pones una ramita pues en
realidad gira lo mismo en cualquier lado
verdad y además quien en sentido
contrario a las manecillas del reloj
ahora hagamos un pequeño experimento muy
pequeño que hubiera pasado si en vez de
y si en vez de y ponemos
hagamos este experimento vamos a poner
en vez de menos vamos a poner más 10
entonces aquí tendríamos más y en el
determinante aquí sería la derivada
parcial respecto de y de no de menos 10
sino de más 10 y al final aquí
hubiéramos tenido un más tenido un más
uno por lo tanto nos queda que el
rotacional sería cero es decir no hay
rotación que nos dice la intuición de
esto bueno matemáticamente el rotacional
cero pues de alguna forma dice que la
rotación en la dirección x está sobre
puesta la rotación que genera la
dirección de verdad vamos a ver qué
sucede vamos a cambiar nuestra gráfica
anterior y vamos a actualizarlo a
nuestro nuevo campo vectorial ok
este es nuestro nuevo campo vectorial el
campo y más xj y ahora el rotacional es
cero en todos lados lo que significa que
si yo pongo una ramita en cualquier
lugar de aquí no voy a observar ningún
tipo d
rotación
veamos si esto tiene sentido si pongo la
ramita en el centro o algún tipo de palo
en no sé en el centro veamos lo que
tendría son las fuerzas o un fluído
presionando en esta dirección pero no
está ayudando a rotar y luego también
presionando en otra dirección bueno
tampoco nos está ayudando por lo que no
va a rotar si vemos ahora de este lado
probablemente una ramita pueda ser
empujada pero va a ser empujada hacia
afuera por el flujo del agua pero no
rota verdad por ello nuestra intuición
parece que se sostiene esto sucede
porque tengo un rotacional que en la
dirección xy en la dirección que se
sobreponen así que en dos dimensiones no
hay rotación esto en realidad se le
conoce como y rotacional esa es la
palabra un campo vectorial y rotacional
si piensas en la fuerza o en una
velocidad de todo el campo vectorial en
realidad te aplicas una traslación una
traslación de los objetos en ese campo
ahora
sólo por diversión vamos a ver ya cómo
es la divergencia no sé por qué pues
tengo dos minutos restantes así que no
sé qué otra cosa hacer
yo podría calcular esta divergencia de
forma muy fácil déjenme borrar todo esto
digo siempre es divertido interpretar un
campo vectorial hasta hasta que muera
verdad la divergencia de un campo
vectorial es solo la derivada parcial de
la primera parte digamos de iu respecto
de x en la divergencia de b es el
operador nabla punto el vector el campo
vectorial verdad y entonces como les
decía es la derivada parcial respecto de
x de la primera componente que es 0 y la
derivada parcial respecto de y de la
segunda componente que es 0 así que la
divergencia de este campo es al final 0
que quiere decir esto tendrá estos
sentidos
veamos bueno si hacemos un círculo
alrededor del origen porque esto es
bastante interesante cuando tenemos a un
fluído o partículas que vienen a cierta
velocidad desde la parte de abajo a la
derecha y de la parte de arriba a la
izquierda pues en realidad se se restan
de los que están en la dirección
verdad cualquier cosa que salga se
compensa con lo que entra verdad tomando
lo aquí en el centro pero bueno ahí no
hay ningún incremento de densidad neta
ni mucho menos como ya hemos visto en
los vídeos de divergencia ahora vamos a
ver qué pasa si tomamos otro lugar si yo
toman un círculo por aquí digamos aquí
la divergencia es cero lo cual nos
indica que cualquier cosa que entre en
cierta dirección sale en otras
direcciones por lo que no me estoy
volviendo denso ni menos ni más no hay
divergencia ni convergencia bueno esto
es bastante interesante pero ya se acabó
el tiempo hemos terminado el análisis
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo